[Music]
hello there hope everyone's doing well
so i'm about a week ago some images of
ill mcgregor going to the set of kenobi
leaks where we can slightly see his new
outfit that we've heard about
and for some context there was an
interview a little while ago i
think i'm jimmy kimmel but i could be
wrong where his el mcgregor was saying
he's going to have a new outfit
for this show um i take two things from
this possibly he's referring to
his clone wars outfit and like
flashbacks potentially or for the
entirety of the show who have a
completely new outfit
and different to what we've seen before
um and if we actually look at these
pictures
and compare it to images from his
episode 3
and episode 4 outfit you can actually
see it's different if you look at his
sleeves he can tell it's a bit darker
than usual compared to his other outfits
which is a whitish color however if we
look at another image of leaked
we see another cast member wearing a
very very similar type of outfit
compared to uh mcgregor so this could
mean two things
this could be his um stunt double so
then obviously he will be wearing the
same outfit
or he could be a civilian character
so let's say he's a civilian character
that means oh mcgregor's or i should say
obi-wan's outfit
is uh more civilian-like so it means
he's trying to
blend in more um which would make sense
because that's what he's trying to do
he's trying to hide on tatooine and
you know look after luke and stuff but
yeah that's interesting to me because if
this is his
new outfit will we see him get his um
episode four outfit later on on the show
or will he just have this new outfit for
the whole entire show
before we wrap up the video there was
also a storm trooper
shown um going to the set of kenobi you
can see he's
trying to hide himself but obviously we
we know it's a stormtrooper
anyway guys that's it for this video so
please let me know in the comments below
what do you think of this new outfit do
you think he'll get his episode for
outfit towards the end of the show
you